Scummy noab
Lets flow
It's lee
Mario
Mushroom
browser down
laughttttt
Mario
Meme review
Thats the sound of your mum hayyyy
It's me Gloria Borger here for special news report an announcement meme related an egg
Has overtaken Kylie Jenner as the most liked Instagram post ever
my god
That is crazy, I know I'm not supposed to give my opinion but
Wow an egg. Can you imagine getting beaten by an egg. Now the most liked
Now the most liked picture Instagram is an egg everybody pat yourself on the back you did it
26 million likes! let's set a world record together and get the most liked post on Instagram
Being the current record Kylie Jenner I bet you how to basic is just shaking right now
He's like why did I not think of that I think the verge posted this the best
What a time to be alive an egg. Picture gets the most likes what a time to be alive
2019 this is crazy an egg.
AN EGG!!!
An freaking egg. Are you kidding me I'll let you post give my prayers but gotta crazy
Kylie Jenner had the best response
I mean her response was stop I was like I can't wait to see Kylie Jenner's reaction to this
I bet she's gonna have the right thing to say to just make everyone go, whoa
Kylie: Alright guys
Kylie: First lets feel the ground.
Pewds:Take that little egg
Kylie: really hot. okay
She reposted someone else's meme
👏👏👏
Kylie Jenner I challenge you fight me next time. I'm not afraid to hit a child how about how about Kylie Jenner vs Pewdiepie?
Like this egg
That's all you had to say
So an egg is now the most like picture in instagrams history
How?
EGG-celent.
is this kind of things that just makes me want to not live just this is the reason why I can't be enthusiastic about things.
Just stop.
This is brilliant.
But I like this.
I'm giving the egg meme an egg. 26 billion of them
👏
That's a lot of eggs! Now we can only get all those eggs to subscribe to Pewdiepie then we can beat T-series.
EGGS
I'm calling upon all eggs
You subscribe to Felix we can beat all Kylie Jenners sorry
I don't like How to Basic.
What other motives do you need?
Subscribe my eggs. My fellow eggs
I call upon thee in the time of great danger
Subscribe to PewDiePie.
NEXT MEME 👏👏👏
We got that uh-huh what you got there?
Smoothie
Get it? Because he's holding a smoothie. Now people made a different version of this meme.
Uhh. What you got there? What you got there? yeah what are you got?
Smoothie
No, you're not you're holding a Tik Tok thot, and a smoothie.
😤😤😤
woah 😤😤😤
You guys seeing this? is it just me
IS IT JUST ME?
Or is my G
*wheezes and pants*
Wait can I drink myself?
Is that even possible?
🎶🎶🎶 INTENSE MUSIC 🎶🎶
*sneezes* owo
🎶🎶🎶 INTENSE MUSIC 🎶🎶🎶
To access this content you must download the DLC PewDiePie PACK
JUST KIDDING 😀😀😀
What you got there?
Smoothie Smoothie Smoothie
Cop: huh what you got there?
Typical American: just a gun
Kinder egg surprise. This is crazy. I just found this out. In America kinder egg
Surprises is unlegal did you guys even have a childhood?
smh. pathetic.
Hey you know it's not a meme until someone makes a world war two joke
"Horoshima" yes that's how it's spelled
Nagasaki: um what you got there?
USA
Two atomic bomb.
Smoothie.
So that's how they did it
💲💲💲💲💲
Wha? Another news report segment?
Gloria Borger here again for another meme review
news
this is it boys, we have found Big Chungus
I. R. L.
Karen
Chungus
chunga, chunga, chunga, chunga, chunga chunga, chunga, chung
Karen Chungus is a real person that people discovered on facebook
chunga, chunga, chunga, chunga, chunga, chunga, chunga, chunga
Do you hear that?
She's an anti-vax 😀😀😀 of course she is
Of course she's anti-vaxx 😀😀😀
Mother of two beautiful children who are
Unvaccinated.
Not only does Karen Chungus is named Chungus, she looks
IDENTICAL to Big Chungus
CHUNGA, CHUNGA, CHUNGA, CHUNGA, CHUNGA, CHUNGA, CHUNGA
Are you guys hearing that or what? I'm not supposed to give my opinion but do you guys hear that sound?
Level one Crook.
Level hundred Mafia Boss Karen Chungus.
CHUNGA, CHUNGA, CHUNGA, CHUNGA
CHUNGA-OOH, CHUNGA OOH, BIG CHUNGA
I swear there's a
next meme
This is not even a meme
I'm just reviewing this so you guys will stop.
Stop obsessing over every single girl that appears on Tik Tok.
Everyone's reposting this girl dancing to that:
Where is Scooby-Doo, we're coming after you we gotta solve that mystery Where is Scooby-Doo
Listen we already had the Hit or Miss craze
I don't want another one. Just please guys stop. Find a girl IRL.
Okay?
Stop being such a loser and obsess over Tik Tok girls.
Just stop.
It's not gonna go anywhere.
She just wants you for likes and clout.
She doesn't want you for your nothing, you got nothing to offer either I don't know
😀😀😀
Aww that tastes good.
G-Fuel PewDiePie flavor.
😀😀😀
Thanks Felix 👍👍👍
👏👏👏
James Charles.
🎶 ominous music 🎶
You guys heard about this?
You guys know about this?
James Charles
Everyone's favorite beauty fashion guru, blogger makeup person James Charles
which we all thought we knew
transforms however at night
into a dark creature
James Charles is in every horror movie ever how could we have been so blind
No sister, bye sister, oh my gosh it's pewdiepie!
watch out
Yes anything can become a meme in 2018-2019 whatever year it is
Chad has just called out one of the prisoners to make contact with him
If this is a portal to Hell, slam a door!
You can cross over.
James: HI SISTERS
Pewds: Oh my gosh! *chuckles*
Holy crap
Alright I'm tired of this James Charles is in every horror ever I just want to play a nice little game like Minecraft, okay?
Peaceful difficulty.
Maybe I'll step it up a little? Okay normal. Maybe I'll just hard.
Okay.
Or maybe I'll - Oh that's really difficult.
James again: HI SISTERS!
God damn it! God damn it James Charles I've had enough of you
James: HI SISTERS
👻 👻 👻
He stayed this way for 50 minutes
James Charles died. James Charles died! Okay. Is my. No!
Oh no!
😢 😢 😢 😢 😢
It is limp like my small manhood
This has been the saddest meme review in so long.
Maybe we have time for bonus?
It's worth a shot what the?!
calling on Brad
Brad? Do we have time for bonus meme?
Only
if you enter the code PewDiePie and buy all the G-Fuel stock for 30% off?
WAIT
Which technically means you can't just buy 30% more you can actually buy
42.9% more. Is that what you said?
Show bonus meme?
BONUS MEME!
A thousand years of good fortune upon you!
We have time for bonus meme!
Oh my god. I thought bonus meme was dead!
This only happens once every comet sunshine fall!
Okay, what do we got?
Person 1:  Sir, the price is $10 but we'll charge five dollars more for shipping.
Person 2: Nah, that's too much.
Person 1: Okay, $15 price with free shipping!
Person 2: Shit, that's all you had to say!
Does every meme in 2019 have to have some sort of racially undertone to it? I like it. Keep it up!
Her: Wanna come over to ffffffuhhh ;)
Him: No go away
Her: We can watch Star Wars Episode III Revenge of the Sith afterwards?
Him: Shit, *chuckles* That's all you had to say! I really want to say the n-word. Not because I want to say the n-word!
But because I'm racist (pfff) When the skippable ad says "Wait! Wait, don't skip this ad!"
Shit! *giggles*
I saw you had se- I love this meme. It's beautiful.
EA: We changed the number of the- on the cover
Shit, that's all you had to say! I'll buy another one! Get it FIFA fans?
You're stupid!
They're just changing the number on the cover they're not changing anything else.
It's the same with the Apple fans.
Oh, hey, look We have the same product just a hundred pounds more expensive!
That's all you had to say!
Mom: Finish your vegetables
Me: I don't want to.
Mom: Finish your vegetables or no dessert.
Well shit! That's all you had to say!
There's a count if you read it in your head. Right?
Anakin: Is it possible to learn this power?
Senate: Not from a Jedi
Anakin: Shit, that's all you had to say!
Hey look here this!
Apple: We added another hundred dollars to the price tag Apple fans: *bleep*
Hold on, this whole operation was your idea
Oh, I love this. This is so great.
When your teacher calls on you to read the page in how to kill a mockingbird
With the n-word but you read it with too much enthusiasm and get a detention
hold on this whole
Operation was your idea?
Bonus Bonus 👏👏👏
Meme we did it guys we absolutely did it this means T-Series is destroyed this means 👏👏👏👏👏
no more 👏👏👏
controversies this means you have to smash like on this video buy the merch and 👏👏👏
Check out g-fuel link in description sponsored video down below 👏👏👏
Thank you guys! 👏👏👏
Go and live a life 👏👏👏
Go and live a happy life 👏👏👏
Bonus bonus meme 👏👏👏
Jesus Christ I'm just gonna I'm gonna I have to go I have to tell someone
*throws headphones*
You want pyramids? We got em! Oh, you're into castles, huh? We got you covered baby! You want some pets? Easy!
We got it all!
This game is still relevant, god damn it
this took me so long help